up to astro make sure you guys go and
show them some love give them a follow
for what they've done here not only in
tekken but in the community as a whole
with that being said i know you guys
have been hearing us talk smack
but we are going to take a quick break
oh it's just a hype video oh okay sorry
about that
we're gonna take i just said i wanted a
package of glaciating and we have one
here it is your king of the hill
champion glaciating
take it away
damn look at glaciating prowess oh my
god wall bounce power crush again
glaciating is just too strong it's
glaciating what else can we see
maybe glaciating this cold oh but it's
getting
beat though 3-0
over pbx he is your new king of the hill
big wild glaciating appearance man this
is wild
then the
the last thing you want to do is get
really irritated and try to throw him
back
oh my god he got in his head he got in
his head
the king of kings as you guys saw
and that was just one of the quite a few
highlight of the runs
that we've seen uh glaciating put up for
the king of the hill challenges so far
uh i know you guys saw that highlight
reel but if you were there for some of
those matches you would understand
why why everybody is aiming for
a player like glaciating why has the
name that he has and why he
is the king of kings here and the final
king of the hill
challenger for none other than ben chang
another heavy hitter in the world of
online tekken 7
we've seen these guys go head to head
multiple times not only in icfc
but in the preseason of icfc you know
and even what bud light beer league
these guys got to play a little bit if
i'm not mistaken
there's a lot of history behind this
match there's a lot of history behind
these players
mark i can't wait to actually get into
this to see who's going to be our winner
here
i wonder what the chat thinks i wonder
who they think is gonna come out on top
these guys have obviously played each
other before in different tournaments
and
we've had mixed results you know i feel
like more often than not though we've
seen glaciating come out on top
especially recently but again it all
comes down to this set that they're
gonna play right now it's gonna be a
race to three
and only one of them will be crowned as
the king of the hill for these series
oh and there he is the miguel
that's his answer miguel
versus ben chang we've seen it time and
time again
the king of the hill finale comes down
to two of the heaviest hitters in online
tech and it's going to be ben chang
going up against glaciating the [ __ ]
rom versus miguel
765 all around that's the tekken god
omega let's go oh the namukul
the 765 let him know here we go starting
it off nice slow parry
into the wall
i mean you know it's crazy too because
we've been watching you know glaciating
as king of the hill in a lot of these
challenge sets
and i remember seeing something and this
is something that really kind of
defines his role as king of the hill one
of his competitors in between matches
i think it was dylan wave was just in
the chat and he was like i'm fighting
for my life
man and that's exactly what a lot of
people think when they're going up he's
glaciating he's that strong of an
opponent
oh kills the blue stuff first round
going to benching round
two and remember guys this is a first to
three
to see who will be the final community
champion for this king of the hill
series
that savage dance down back three doing
some work right now do it again though
oh yeah and i think the key that we're
gonna see here with glaciating is his
timing and the way he lands the low move
those low attacks it's he's such a
surgeon with it he knows when to pick
apart his enemy
oh my god counter hit big damage could
get the wall
oh you might be dead bro oh real close
erotic care the down back three to close
out one round
a piece then i wasn't sure if that
damage was gonna kill but the follow-up
did
i mean harotta care but glaciating dope
right you don't care he's gonna go in
the way these guys are dashing and
waiting for opportunities is insane
try to go for the double savage stance
low he says nothing doing
gets the launcher this time around looks
for the unblockable the duck for
awareness
oh wild finishes the string went to one
plus two
[Music]
tries to go for it again counter hit oh
my god the savage stands down four two
as well
and the natural counter hit savage
stands down three four
four fight and now glaciating looking to
run away with it
this is the first match in this race to
three
[Music]
oh my gosh again look at the way he's
using those loads he's really able to
open up his opponent
oh wow nice the unscaled damage on top
of it after the break
back once that should be the first match
and it was a counter hit at that that
means ben chang was trying to do
something
miguel was gonna tell him man you better
be careful you're gonna get yourself
killed out here man i'm not these
regular guys bro i'm the king of the
hill
you see who's controlling me i see him i
can see glacier he got a stopwatch he
got a timer
he's like yep i'm gonna counter hit him
right now i know he's gonna press a
button
boop and he hit it every single time
whether it was magic for whether it's
the punch attack
he was able to pull it all out and look
at it that was a pretty dominant i would
say
i i'm not going to be surprised if we
see a character switch yeah well i guess
we're going to find out um
vin chang was looking pretty clean uh at
first in some of those first spots but
you can never count out glaciating
glaciating has put in the most work i
feel like with miguel as well as just
kind of
he's really good at implementing that am
i going to do a low again meta
and like if you eat those you're taking
chunks that gets annoying you start to
feel them in the back like at the back
of your head
you're like man why does it keep hitting
me with these lows but they add up super
fast and the minute you try to retaliate
boom counter hit
hop kick some in some instances actually
don't really use that many hopkins he's
more about the pokes and just taking off
chunks of damage
with the neutral game but still got to
be careful i don't know steve this is
this is
honestly how i feel i mean you're a
strong player you're one of the biggest
and the baddest let's say you're the
titanic
but unfortunately today you're going up
against the big glacier that is
glaciating
hey hey dang bars bars yo you think you
can survive it if leo dicaprio couldn't
survive it man i'm just saying bro that
door can't fit us all
okay that door can't fit us all we're
gonna go back in
ben chang going up against none other
than glaciating i mean look at his
character panels it's the
water he's gonna drag you down under the
sea and make you sleeping with the
fishes right now he's already has that
lead he's up one zero here we go
oh this is a good stage oh this is a
good stage when it comes to destruction
oh no didn't go for the wall break but
he caught you duncan gonna get the wall
catches the tech with the down 4-1 oh
counter hit this time and this
is looking like it's gold seven golden
letters with the perfect in the game
number two
dashing in this time now he's taking the
initiative offensively he is making it
count
down back four getting a little more
expansive with the lows this time around
and then back to the savage stand slow
all pokes gets the punch perry he can
get the wall this is a pretty small
stage
oh big damage oh my god
but here comes glaciers black shooting
back dash blocked and loaded ready to go
wasn't ready for that and you saw the
quick duck to kind of adjust to the low
but he got hit by the unblockable tries
to spin the blue stuff and stuff says no
sir
i got enough blue around my neck i don't
need yours
savage stance blocks the low didn't
believe no punish he didn't like my
titanic reference he didn't like they
definitely didn't like that because bing
chang is right now
he's putting in work he's up two rounds
to none here in match number two
ben chang's like what about the old lady
what if i'm the old lady
what if i threw the diamond back into
the ocean and that diamond is glaciated
three rounds straight it looks like can
close out if this wall break
works like it's supposed to but actually
gets the caddy corner chance glaciating
with the opportunity watch for the
savage stand slow
and i say no to the boom stuff nothing
doing
i don't even want it on the side i don't
want no blue stuff
he got stuffed on the rage drive twice
in in both of those rounds where he went
for it and
man again talking about you know having
a read on your opponent and knowing when
to do certain things
bing chang completely flipped the script
from what we saw in the last match
completely 1-1 1-1 tied up baby
people in the chat man y'all are abusing
the titanic metaphor look man his name
is glaciating okay
glaciating how do we know that
glaciating isn't the evolved form of
that same glacier we don't even know
what if the glacier had a kid
and made him start playing tekken what
if this is the revenge of the glacier
glaciating all right i'ma stop all right
now
i'm done but i'm just saying glaciating
is nice with it bro that's all i love
appreciating is
is the iceman he is omega level bobby's
drinking the building bobby drake in the
building
he is detecting god omega level i'm just
saying
my man in the chat say steve is making
sense to me i'm just being real
humble bunny humble bonnet you know how
i get down this is tekken we're talking
about
i appreciate everybody out there
watching man and i hope you guys
are letting making sure that bandai
namco knows being esports and those as
well as astro one of our sponsors here
making some noise for those guys showing
love i appreciate y'all hanging out man
all right here we go it's tied up now
one a piece
i mean that this was not what i expected
i didn't
think bing chang was to come out come
back that hard look
this game that game looked completely
different that game looked completely
different
all right here we go violet system shout
outs to violet in the poolside stage
though
i can't wait i can't wait we got two
days for that though my man got two
stages in tekken 7. that's how you know
he balling he had to pay extra for that
my man's got his whole factory in there
first off he's
look he's advertising right now then
he's got the house it's like mtv cribs
all over bro
big damage yo bin chang bin chang this
is first of three
there is no run backs on this there's no
loser side for the king of the hill
challenge
oh savage stands low was going forward
again and go straight to the mid bin
chang playing and fast forward and this
is not the pace that glaciating is used
to i feel like
i feel like if he's not the one getting
those big hits to whip punish
full crumple you're definitely going to
the wall
don't tech he did anyway gets out of
danger
keeping him there nice
oh a 401 all right here comes glaciating
man bing chang is actually playing out
of his mind right now
look at the way he's just standing there
like a wall you got you have to man
those t-rex arms definitely start to add
up this second game
this third game looking like the second
win for ben chang
two rounds to none in game number three
bin chang is looking really strong right
now he's poised here to take the lead
he's just one round away to do so
and that will put glaciating into a very
uncomfortable position
mark man that that combo that you just
saw glaciating do is one of my favorite
in the game
oh oh trying to hit my man with the
unblockable he's there back one chill
out with all that stuff
my man smacked him in the face you'll
chill out with that unblockable stuff
he's like i'm a boxer too i got one of
those blatant lows
the standing throat spins the blue none
for you
dashing in savage stance two i got blue
stuff
oh the one down three ironically
therefore won the defense looking good
bitching blocks the low and one slow and
the slow play i'm telling you right now
that string is so important to [ __ ]
around play you got to be ready to
defend against it
glaciating says i am blocks it gets the
punish
and we're going into another game
that was that was intense oh savage do
it again
don't listen to me bro you just got
counter hit are we going through the
wall probably not
but damn close never mind probably yes
didn't get the full hit there but still
did a lot of damage not just that
positioning is
his key oh he blocked it oh the paces
like you said before savage stands long
no spins the blue again he says i don't
want it
big nasty hooks no thank you
you almost had it there oh oh oh
back back to space in a lot
just about 15 seconds left using the
tackle blue stuff for you you doing rush
into these knees
you gonna rush into these knees let me
see the blue stuff in the chat yo taste
buds i know you got em
boom squad i know you got him let me see
that blue stuff in the chat
we're selling blue stuff and we are not
only talking about these sick
good ass tekken shirts we're selling
blue stuff out here
that was a that was crazy because you
know he put himself into position he
went for the shoulder charge
but bin chan called him out he's like i
know you're going to do something i know
you're going to press something you're
going to move
you're going to try to do something and
you hit him with the rage drive he was
like bam bam let me give you my knees
he sent my man up the blue river he's
like yo you want to see my blue no look
at my blue the big knees
yo shout out to all the taste buds
showing that no showing me the blue
stuff in the chat it's a lot baby
it's a lot baby this is the king of the
hill challenge
we could potentially be going into our
final match and the run back between
these two phenomenal players two of the
best players in the united states at
this point
especially when it comes to the online
side of things it's looking like ben
chang is the guy right now but i'm
telling you right now glaciating in this
miguel
could easily bring this back we could
easily be getting another game out of
this
so the last time that these guys played
at icfc it was during
uh week number nine in the grand finals
bin chang was able to reset it
3-2 and then he won the reset
oh so i don't know man there's a there's
a lot of there's a lot of history
between these players they obviously
have played against each other many a
time
but anyways that being said what could
potentially be the final match between
these two
here we go it's gonna get interesting
it's gonna get spicy and once again this
stage was picked on purpose by glacier
the violet systems he likes hearing the
robots in the background maybe
you mentioned too i like what you
mentioned man our boy violet he's
balling he's falling
he paid for stage exclusivity and he put
himself in the background too
that's some real corporate bucks at play
right there
finish at the stream this time and we
saw that kind of work out for him in
that first game
oh no unblockable big bench my man is
marching
i mean he lost the positioning but he
got all that damage and one more he
could do oh my god
let me see it in the chat he's not dead
though harada carried the down back
three to close it out oh man
round two he's fighting for his life you
know glaciating cannot lose
or it's all over he will have made his
run as king of the hill
holding the crown for most of the season
and it will be all for naught if bin
chang is able to win this match
lots of poke starting to add up for
glaciating glaciating give me another
one
yeah i want one of these players only
one of these players steve is going to
get the crown royale
who's going to get it i want another
match though stop playing with me
glacier stop playing with oh the low
parry
stop playing with me you know how my low
period is i didn't even realize that his
player title says i'm my mama's name
i think he did that for you steve i
think he did it for you you're a hell of
a
dead
oh my mama
what's going to happen no he's close
he's playing oh no while
standing three you know he's seen that
before trying to go for that follow-up a
lot of people get hit by their bench and
says nah bruh
nah bruh not this time
yeah that down 4-2 series able to land
here he has the wall as well the knees
oh get up three savage two do it again
go respect the standing three oh yeah
jabs down back three of his own one down
three i like the pokes
gonna need something bigger though oh
blue stuff he just spilled it all over
the floor can i get some more
let me see that blue stuff in the chat i
love using this emote by the way
it's fun it's definitely fun two rounds
to one here glaciating looking to tie
things
up give me another definitely has
momentum on the side the jumping punch
are you serious yeah
up four one give me another i want
another match glaciating you from
missouri
hear my call give me another match
savage two got oh that could have been
so much worse
glaciating got lucky right there savage
stands two to answer back
oh my god this is you
i don't know i don't know what that
means but it sounds sick hit him with
the lightning
hit him with the lightning
you see it did you see the lightning
around his shoulders either bing chang
is going to take
the entire king of the hill series or
it's going to be glaciating to tie it up
over barry what a read and not just that
momentum positioning has the wall
oh god oh the duck was sick
get your ass on this wall oh savage load
do it again
oh you got oh my god you want to hit
this other wall for sure you don't hit
this other wall for sure fine
blocks it down 4-1 looking for the low i
like the fuzzy down back four savage
stands two
uh-oh the blue stuffing for the rage
drive the one-two
oh my god oh down back three we have
one more match one more match let's go
down to the last match
let's go i don't know steve
it's a i can't call it this is this is
going down
let's go the very end let's go
i know i know you're feeling some kind
of way you are a miguel player as well
yes you love to see this player or this
character used at its highest potential
and again glaciating just one of the
best out there not just with miguel but
just with
with the entire cast oh yeah oh yeah the
thing about it is is that
even if you guys are new here for the
untrained
tekken eye miguel has definitely been a
character that glaciating has been using
from the very
beginning to literally put people out of
tournaments and win them and then you
have ben
chang another player who's been always
up there when it comes to the world of
tekken
you guys are truly getting some good ass
tekken right now and it's online
and we've had an entire series of events
to lead up to this point i've held an
event you heard little major talking
about it
as well um it's been so cool to get up
to this point but
now we're at our last match of the king
of the hill
community events please let me know man
please let me know how you guys are
feeling and please tell me that you guys
are gonna
make sure the bandai namco knows how
much you guys love these events cause
personally
like i said it's been so long since i've
been on the mic with mark man
it's good these matches are good it's
all paying out we have one more match
mark man real quick who's gonna win tell
me now
answer my question mark man who's gonna
win i want glaciating to win
what do you got steve um
don't don't don't pick just to be
different so with your heart i'm gonna
pick with my heart right i'm gonna pick
with my heart
i'll look i'm a missouri guy man i'm
from the midwest i want glaciating to
win
but i honestly want the better player to
win and i really just only want some
good ass tekken
i don't care who cooks it i just want it
to be good final match
the community hit the king of the hill
community finals this is gonna be sick
okay here we go starting it off and
we're in the jungle baby you know it's
about to get wild
i can't believe it's come down to the
final match this is crazy this is crazy
i thought glaciating was out of it
yo somebody said it in the chat thank
you for the reminder this i'm from the
show me state
missouri show me glaciating show me you
want to win
says it on the license place baby show
me
oh man it's looking really good for
binching though oh and he closes it out
with that nice slow
round takes the first round draws first
blood here in this final match
um savage my man's going too much to the
lows ben chang's starting to test after
every first load
and now just clean blocking him now yeah
and that's that's a big difference if
he's starting to block things i feel
like glaciating is going to start making
adjustments as well because he's not
going to let that happen
defense has been one of the things that
glaciating has really excelled at and
this kept them alive
like turning in tournaments right but i
feel like the fact that ben chang
and glacier have run across each other a
lot the fact that you know miguel still
has this issue when it comes to reaching
kind of like opening people up is
definitely starting to add up
oh the blue stuff he's definitely
getting the wall it's gonna be a guess
it's gonna be a guess big damage huh
potential final round glaciating give me
two rounds
i'm gonna that's a good ass button
that's a good ass button that is
definitely a good ass button that's a
prime ingredient and good ass ticket
nice punish glaciating i need you i need
i need you now
uh uh oh the hard stuff the hard stuff
block that could have been a lot worse
oh
my man just did it he said show me
you're gonna do the string i'm from
missouri
show me we got another round let's go he
said
show me that you're going to do me show
me your about that life bing chang
glaciating showing that momentum is not
phasing him at all you know bing chang
going out strong with two straight
rounds but glaciating took that back
super quick
my man said show me you see this silver
i'm a multiple person
this is not going to be good this is not
going to be good at all but the sidewall
does save him there
oh he's ready
two oh my god he knows that that could
have been the round
the down four the blue he didn't block
it low but the wall might save him
oh my god you have to drive oh my god
the staff up sport one
savage stand slow ben chang knew was
coming he will be your
king of the hill champion taking out
none other
than one of the strongest competitors on
the us side of things
it will be none other than ben chang yo
can we make some noise in the chat man
what a tournament bro what
tournament what not only a tournament an
amazing king of the hill challenge
series at the very end
a fun-filled day i mean we had character
announcement coming out in just two days
steve
look man this is the field right here
you said yourself man me and you haven't
been on the mic talking since uh talking
about tekken since november bro
and now we came we delivered to you the
good ass tekken we had some dope ass
matches we gave you some good ass
merch we gave you a sick ass character
what more do you want from us what more
do you want from us you we've given you
everything we've hit every check box
what do you need at this point to let
you know that all we want
is good ass tekken man and i hope you